for part two of
quantum
um two let me again start with
summary
Yer we talked about um constructions and
these constructions utilized So-Cal CS
codes which are defined
by two
um
checkes HX
and HZ and the all important uh
condition was that uh
HX
hos has to be zero okay and um as a
first uh uh idea here was um kind of
maybe we can kind of construct codes
similarly as we construct them in the
classical realm which is just taking
random par check matrices but then we
very quickly saw that this condition uh
essentially throws a wrench into this so
there's no um n random
constructions and maybe somebody
remembers why that
was because it's the one code has good
distance the other one can't exactly yes
because because um the checks of one
code are code words of the other code
yeah um yeah so if if this is a really
good code then um this one can't have
Spar checks yeah but we want both
matrices to be Spar in order to be ldpc
um yeah so we want something we need
something more
sophisticated result for any c just
for it's only it's only if you want to
kind do this naive construction yeah if
you just kind of naely sample this to be
a random spots Matrix yeah then it
doesn't work then then then we kind of
run into this this trouble that we can't
also kind of randomly sample this one in
these
bars I I mean I think it's isn't it true
in general for the distance of the
classical codes but it's not true for
the distance of the Quantum Code because
you're modding out of course of course
yeah yeah code statement is always true
exactly exactly yeah yeah um so let me
let me let me kind of it Point home in a
minute because I I saw like I had a few
questions where people were confused
about this so let me just kind of say
one more thing and then I'll kind of
give you again the geometric
ination so uh what we seen after this uh
was that we can
obtain um uh CS codes so HX and HZ um by
subdividing many
Folds
and I use this word kind of very Loosely
what I mean it's just kind of subdivided
into like vertices edges faces and high
dimensional objects yeah and then just
look at the incidence relationship and
this incidence relationship gave me my
my parity check matrices oh yeah and
importantly um these manifolds have to
be off
Dimension lar than two yeah um okay and
um yeah so the kind know kind of driving
this this point back home about about
which codes are have high distance and
which ones have low distance so um if we
look at uh the code which is checked by
um HX so this called
C then um remember we have seen one
example which was the Tor code yeah and
we've seen that the uh the elements in
CZ were all uh configurations of
loops on the SD yeah um and uh
uh CX per which is the the code that we
mod out in the CSS
construction um are
all
boundaries yeah so just to kind of draw
an
example so uh an element of CX per would
be something like
this yeah but there are Loops which are
not boundaries
namely this one right so we want we want
uh the code which only contains which
doesn't contain these nonv Loops yeah we
want this one to have very low distance
yeah because this will be our our checks
like the like some bases will will give
us our our our checks yeah and we want
the other which also contains these like
long uh these uh these non Loops these
one should be very long
yeah
okay all right um yeah so we have seen
the the the Tory code um which was a
very nice very simple construction and
it gave us a code with distance scaling
as square root of n yeah just because
the shortest non Tri Loop has has length
square of N and then there I kind of did
this bit where I kind of explained
explained in ination marks the the fre
my construction which was very very
complicated uh and they obtained uh a
distance uh fourth root of log
n uh SC
n okay uh so this
wasu um and the important ingredient
here
was uh
twisting of the of the
manifold okay um but then I said uh
maybe there's like another way of of
constructing codes and this will be the
the main chunk of what I'm going to talk
about today and I already kind of talked
about a little bit yesterday which was
uh taking products actually let me just
kind of here
alternatively can
construct by taking
prods okay
so let me um reiterate uh this a little
bit um to remind
you um so first of all uh we've seen
that okay the example I gave you was
essentially this
one where we have two circles and I
argued that a circle I can identify with
a repetition
code
where the vertices are my
checks and the edges are my bits
and then I product I
obtain tus yeah and this was exactly the
T code that we have seen
before and um I I kind of claimed that
if I kind of take more General products
of two codes C and D then uh the
incidence
Matrix between let's say uh edges VES
uh that I kind of called d one is given
by The Entity and then the incident
Matrix uh of the code uh
d and
then1 c and
then and here okay and the intuition
here was that my um I have two of edges
the now just come from different types
of products um namely whether I take an
edge here times a Vertex here
so Edge
vertex
Edge um okay so let me just kind of just
kind of go through this uh um give you
like one example one very speciic
example so um this is not really a code
but just to kind of show
you uh where this labeling comes from
because somebody asked about this
yesterday and I kind of appreciate that
it's not really obvious so let's call
these two vertices A and B yeah and this
Edge I call V for vertical and this one
I call H and these veres I call zero and
one then what's the the thing I get out
if I can take the condition product
square
square and here my labeling is uh a Comm
Z of this vertex which is the product
between this vertex and this vertex
right and then I have this vertex and
this vertex so here I have
A1 here I have b
z uh
B1 and my edges are just vertical
zero vertical one yeah just this Edge
times this Vertex or this ver T and then
a
and
DH and then um I can check that my Del
one uh is just given so first of all
like uh columns are labeled by the
vertices so um Sorry by the edges so
ah D and
e01 and the uh rows are labeled by the
edges so
a0
A1 b0
B1 okay and then I have um let's say I
look at ah yeah a z and A1 so I have one
one
here and this is all that this Ed is to
simil 0 0 one
one and here I have uh one Z
one
z0 one0 one you Canin yourself this is
exactly here I have the
identity as a product with the uh with
Del one here which is one one and here I
also have d
one so here I have the tensu between the
con product between the identity and and
this one one and similarly on the other
side I have uh the prod between this one
one and the identity Matrix
right yeah so it checks
out okay um so that was just to kind of
uh convince you that it works um okay
and then the other thing I showed you
was the the the K theorem which was
quite nice because it relates um the
code words uh of these input codes of
the factors uh to the um code words that
we care about in the in the quum code so
for example I showed you if I
have my Cod word on the repetition code
here
111 then uh this
becomes this quote word here this non
contracted
BL okay
um and um and this works more generally
so this was shown by
tore hyph product
um and um kind of plugging in uh uh good
um classical codes gives us
parameters and
uh K of order n and D of order square
root
n okay so this again was just
KET
and Kun is not strong enough to kind of
convince us that um that this is
actually the distance right it just kind
of tells us there is a basis which has
which has this this weight yeah but
there might be like some real
cancellations happening um so
um for example what I mean this is not
uh a counter example but let's say um I
take I take this product and let me kind
of just write the t a little bit
differently let me just kind of draw it
in a planer way yeah so the identified
here and here uh what I could do is I
can take an edge
here yeah this would pick up a syndrome
yeah right because uh this um uh this
par check wouldn't be fulfilled right
yeah here but I can cancel it out uh by
kind of adding an edge here right so I
can kind of cancel this non syndrome
with a non here fing an edge here and an
edge here I have this go
doing this until I kind of cre a loop
yeah um but note that uh this actually
has a a larger distance than uh that's
like one of the one of the ones yeah and
uh essentially the the proof is just
kind of going through or kind of doing a
proof by contradiction that if we have
if we have these kind of like mixed um
um uh mixed elements then um we can
always always kind of show that this
will be lower bonded by any of the of
the of the ones that we get from the
that's the high level the high level
view this any questions at
this so what do you mean by the Cod to
be that
like you
said
Lineum what's the quantum State oh I
didn't we don't talk about States here
uh so it okay so
so I really don't want to talk about
this but I mean okay just for you like
the uh the the the the the state is
actually the linear superposition over
all elements in
here yeah and you can see that this
invariant under adding adding any like
boundaries yeah okay and the hidden
information is like the non Loop kind of
hidden in this so that's just the
standard CSS yeah it's just
a um just make sure I understand the
result so does this say that there exist
good codes for which this low hold oh no
we we can just take any we can just take
any is there a reason why you WR the
tensor products with the I on the left
and I on the right because I would have
thought they commuted or something
you're implying oh uh yeah so what I'm
kind of implying here and again kind of
won't maybe won't go probably very
likely won't go into this is because um
this are these are products of of
vertices
right and
edges right so uh it only makes sense to
kind of apply this on the on the
edges why and here it's the other way
around so here it's uh
edges
veres so is it a plus between the two or
no this is a TENS sub product no
round sorry where yeah yeah no it's just
a matrix so this is just like kind I
know this is just like the block
Matrix on the same note that tensor
product there do you think of it as a
tensor product in graphs or do you think
of it more in the chain complexes oh um
the same in this case but I'm not sure
um so mean in this case it's just like a
CRCT between matrices so it's always set
it up uh but I mean just in this idea
that this Loop tensor Loop is Taurus
that's so the top diagram you have Loop
tensor Lo taus yeah so I can think of
that as the tensor between the two
graphs oh okay sorry yeah yeah so okay
okay um so okay so kind of again I I
kind of don't want didn't want to talk
about this so I I actually it is a
tensor product between CH complexes yeah
and what I'm kind of missing here is
del2 right I didn't write down D2 and
I'm not going to but uh but yeah also
graphs right uh yes yeah yeah I mean but
I mean so this is just like a
linearization of this right and we can
always this kind likeing to during my
talk but not going to go
into so another question so here you're
thinking more in terms of parity checks
but I guess you could Define this also
for the basis of generator
Matrix but here we should think of these
defining parity check uh
um yes so I'm not sure understand the
question correctly so I guess you could
take like the the transposes of these
matrics and view these I mean the the
Dual thing of the code it generates yeah
rather than the check but I guess you do
here you think of it as checks because
you want the ldpc property uh yes yes
exactly so I mean so so here um so Del
one will be um I mean this will Lally be
the par check Matrix of the CSS
code yes
[Music]
um um
yeah okay any more questions sorry I'm
still a little bit confused about what
the Dell operators actually are so like
DD d c are those like boundary operators
yeah ex boundary operators so there I
mean again I want to kind avoid
homological algebra in this talk as much
as I can uh but I mean you seem very
eager I mean I'm also happy to kind of
Del into that uh but I mean just as a
matrix like I mean how should I
understand this like it acts on like
sectors of Ed
yeah it acts on vectors of edges and
maps onto vectors
of okay yeah the way I set it up was
just like this an incidence Matrix which
is which is also is the same thing okay
and as an incidence matrix it's given by
the column Vector one one is am I
reading your notation correct yeah right
so so just kind of plugging plugging in
like like this is just one Edge right
kind of plug this in and I get like one
one on the get the boundaries which are
just the two vertices here
okay please is write down the Matrix
one uh you mean you mean
here yeah that's the that's that's the
Matrix L1 for
this no this is the full this is
essentially like this one I just wrote
down this one explicitly for this like
little example
okay any more
questions yes so in this case if we
commute CN D we don't take the same oh
yeah yeah but I mean that just happens
to be because like I took the same quote
here right but I mean like I mean if I
made this one larger I would kind of get
like a maybe have like a thin taus and
otherwise I would like a thick tus which
is shorter
yeah the hyper code why are the cubits
on these diagonal
lines
lines I was giving an example of of of a
of a non-trivial loop yeah which doesn't
only consist of horizontal or only of
vertical edges but you can have like
mixed and then the the the thing I want
to kind of get into was essentially for
the distance you have to kind of also
take this into account obviously yeah
because K only talks about like the ones
which are kind of in one in one sector
yeah and what you have to do is
essentially kind of show that there has
no no way to kind of have like weird
cancellations such that the the
resulting Loop becomes shorter yeah yeah
and this cannot happen in this in this
product
okay all right
um okay very good um so everybody on
board with uh with Hyper
prods okay good um okay so then let's
move on to uh good QC
codes
and um we have already kind of seen the
the key ingredient uh in the
fre uh example and that is um
introducing twists yeah so let me give
you another example and the example is
of course the Tory
code
um
okay so here uh can everybody tell me
the distance of this
code um okay so let me do something uh
uh where I T this tus yeah and I twist
it yeah so now it looks like this
start
again
[Music]
okay okay so what's the distance now at
least like for this for this
Loop so I go one two 3 four and go back
in here
right
six so without introducing any extra
cubits yeah so my n is the same but I
kind of just did this twist and this
introduces some some detour that now my
my my Loop has to go yeah to uh kind of
go back onto itself to actually be a
proper Loop yeah and um this is exactly
what happened in this fre construction
because kind of I know mentioning yeah
where we kind of Twisted some minold
yeah and kind generate code from that
and that gave us our extra fourth root
of a log
n um and uh there were some rapid
developments uh between uh uh 2020 and
2021 um where essentially this type of
idea was uh was utilized so let me just
kind of summarize the results so first
ifra
kofman um
gave a an improvement over the fre my
result where we now have an actual
square root not the fourth root of log n
square of n that was in
April uh of 20 then uh
kofman
Tesla improved this further to arbitrary
poly logs
so we have
log
and
S N that was in
August and then there was a bit of a a
breakthrough because um actually many
people kind of U were willing to believe
that this is possible yeah um but I
think there were people some people who
had like an inkling that maybe this is
the best we can do yeah we can only have
like like Po violations of the square
root but then Hing
sound showed that this is actually not
true and they showed that it's possible
to get
distances
um up to n to the
35 over
polys and that was in
September and then P
KV
um further improved this and showed that
actually you can get almost arbitrary
almost linear
distance
um Al two doesn't matter
ala and was in
December okay um all right so we got
almost there the problem here was we had
to kind of give up on the encoding rate
yeah so the encoding rate is also
controlled by Alpha and it would just
vanish PR Alpha to
one okay um the idea uh here is
essentially we take something which is
which is um um a mix out of random and
something which is structured yeah so we
take um like Twisted products of of of
random classical codes yeah
um okay um
so any questions at this stage
or so these are still CSS codes
everything I talk about CSS codes yeah
yeah so when you say twist um I mean
sometimes it's taken to mean that like
know the other side of the boundary is
like literally Z2 flipped and that's how
you make the identifications but here it
seems like
just somewhere in the middle of the
lattice you kind of shifted the
coordinates by by one yes exactly yeah
that's that's that's the the second the
second interpretation is the one that
I'm I'm thinking of yeah and that's the
one used in all of these results that
you yes yes yes exactly yeah um so
there's nothing happening on the on the
level of uh how I do my parity checks at
this stage uh it's all about how I it's
all about like incidences and like how I
chose my inces
okay yes
please
um but at some point at some point for
example if I do if I do it here then at
some point I uh I can have a shortcut
right if I can twist more than 180
degrees I don't actually gain
anything in this example though if you
twisted one more if you went down by two
would you get yes so
it's or something like this yeah yeah
guess Square I guess yeah you don't want
to
okay um okay and then uh another um
result was um uh by myself and Y art and
these were balance prodct
quotes
um and that was also in
December and um so we we were kind of
inspired by this paper by
Hing which as I said was was randomized
and we kind of thought about like okay
what is kind of the geometric structure
behind this and um the way we thought
about this was um through a product
called bance Product which is kind of
like a widely known and used um um
notion in homological ad
and an topology so let me just kind of
introduce this really quick so the idea
is we have some group
G
acting on a topological
Space
X so for
example we can have G to be a cylic
group uh acting on
uh X which
is just the
um Loop graph and just X by rotation
right so it kind of maps some uh some
point x to a point * X rotating rotating
around uh by
rotation um now let's say um we have one
group acting on two spaces
uh x and x
Prime then uh there's a natural action
of
G uh on the
product namely if I have two
points X and Y yeah then I can Define
the product to be x * G inverse and then
G
sorry
y um and maybe intuitively you can
already kind of see that this kind of I
know does some kind of weird twisting uh
in the in the manifold um now the
balance
product B
product is simply uh defined as follows
so we take uh sorry first of all it's
notated as
uh um X and then product with a G and
then this is defined as just the normal
condition product and then I just look
at orbits under this action of
G okay so let just the abct definition
let me give you an
example and again I use the tus uh
convenient so
um um yeah okay so let me first say so
the way we kind of going to use this we
have already kind of shown or kind of
seen that um we can think of of
classical codes vely as topological
spaces associate them with with a cell
complex and look at their incidence
relationship um now the idea is
essentially to take tag graphs of of two
classical codes yeah which are which
have the symmetry which can of share
Symmetry and apply apply this um this
notion of
product so let me use some colors for
this so let's say I have repetition
codes of distance
six
so four five six and another repetition
code of distance
three
and uh on both of these uh I can act by
performing rotations uh of 120 degrees
right I can kind of rotate them uh by
three turns right both of them so I have
uh this
product if I do
this uh first of
all I guess
um I get
[Applause]
tus but it's not the usual
tus but it's a tus which is which is
kind of Highly Twisted so
um kind of
effect have bations so this side
identified with this
side so let me draw it again just as
a uh with this have rolled up it kind of
looks like
this and
then
veres
and then this uh length six one kind of
just uh goes
around in the definition of the balance
codes balance product yeah are you
identifying orbits to a single point yes
exactly yeah yeah yeah exactly that's
what happen sorry I went over this bit
fast but yeah what happens
yeah and um yeah these orbits
essentially kind of become orbits of
checks um yeah and this defines
uh code so if I would kind of so this is
still identified this side with this
side yeah drawing so this is just like
as good as I can do yeah um so imagine
this is just like a taus but now the the
squares are kind of like the lce is kind
of uh Twisted yeah it's not like the
usual Square letters that you would put
on the tus but it's kind of like a
twisted one um and now if you if you do
your counting so first of all we know
that on the tus our uh number of encoded
um um cubits is just a number of nont
Loops that's still two right it's just
it's just theological space it's just a
tus so it's like one kind from this
direction the other going in this
direction um you can also check that the
distance is still three yeah just
because we can have like this Loop kind
of going wrong right theed
Loop however the number of
edges is
12 yeah if you want to get distance
three norator code we would take a
3X3 Square letters
right and then we use's formula and we
see that here n is actually equal to 18
yeah so we reduced um the number of of
cubits that we need yeah but we kept our
our K and our d
invariant that's kind of the the high
level idea here that
um uh by doing this this kind of product
we um uh we still kind of we can kind of
somewhat preserve our our code
properties yeah but we reduce the number
of of
Cub yes please I see you defined uh the
the action like with a right action on X
and a left action on X Prime it's the
same in the case of thean group that you
use but do you use non a bilion yeah in
the end we have to use non a billion
groups and that was essentially also
like one thing which was different from
like these previous Works where we just
used where they just used like
essentially a billion groups um but this
actually allows you to have to non
products um yeah I will get back to that
in a
minute okay um like one additional thing
is you can actually also prove AIT
formula so just as for the hypergraph
product uh it's slightly more
complicated in the sense that here we
have a condition so if the order of
G is
odd then it follows that code
lift okay and this is exactly what
happens here right so we have our our
red Loop lifts to this red Loop and our
long um blue loop kind of lifts to this
blue loop kind of going like in circles
around around the
Tet um
okay so now um the main idea behind uh
constructing good qpc
codes is yes please so it's clear n
decreases because you're identifying
ages yeah same orbit so why don't you
lose anything in the
dimension uh the K will the same oh
because of the formula yeah guarantees
you that as long as like G is not kind
of co-prime with your field in this case
too
um okay but again it's not it's it's not
a guarantee it gives you an upper bound
on the distance right because you might
have created like weird
shortcuts which kind of give you like
shorter Loops yeah but
um gives you like some hope that if you
take um so the
idea take
two uh symmetric good
codes um let's say on N to the
bits and a symmetry
group there's one more question uh yeah
one
second the order of the group is of
order
antia um yeah so question well I guess
maybe say but like symmetric group means
that the group of automorphisms contains
G or something like that yeah so exactly
so that that g kind of Acts on the T
graph
um okay so then the hope is that the the
output uh number of cubits n will first
be N squared until the squared right
which is just due to the normal product
that we already knew the hypergraph
product but then we reduce with respect
to G yeah and if if G acts regularly on
the tener graph uh we reduce the number
of of
cubits and then here we will get uh
antia but
uh
kind of gives you at least the hope so
that uh the distance will preserved so
we get n
Tilla and this will
be be okay so we kind of hope that we
can we can essentially reduce the space
yeah but kind of preserve the the the
loop or the the code word which kind of
lies within it yeah that's kind of the
idea is that that kind of convey this or
and here you don't really care about
you're happy with k equals one even um
well okay actually k k I
know uh K I know will be of of order n
again because of
Kit okay so this brings us okay how do
we even get these symmetric good codes
oh je time
um yeah okay okay but that's okay um
have another 15 20 minutes that's
fine so I can maybe uh do a little
shortcut when I explain SS
Speedman codes
uh so the question is how do we get uh
get these ingredients first of all
so
with uh symmetric classical
Cotes um and these are defined from K
graphs we
some and generating
sets
such that it's uh closed under
inversion um and we Define the graph
just by taking the vertic
set um to be the elements
elements and uh twoes are
connected
um say right this so G connected to G
Prime
only if there exists an S and
S such that g Prime is equal to g s okay
um and we can simply Define a code as we
did before based on um uh the instance
relation between the the the vertices
and edges yeah so we just take the graph
code right um but and we have already
done this right so for example uh G
could again just be the cyclic group CN
and then we get
our our graph now and this was just our
repetition code
right we could do this here but it was
observed by um Z Speedman that we can
actually get a a good classic codes out
of this
so
human um and let me kind of shorten this
a little bit so let me just say uh if
the
graph is uh sufficiently by
connected so what I mean is of
course um and we perform
uh
um local parity
checks
according to a
um uh length length
escod which has sufficient sufficient
distance yeah then the resulting
code uh would be
good yeah so what do I mean by uh um
perform local parity checks According to
some some some uh local
code so let's see let's say I have
uh uh one Pro in my
cigraph looks like
this and um usually I would just perform
par checks among all bits coming into
this vertic yeah but let's say or maybe
let's say five six seven it makes more
sense uh but instead of doing that I
performed the par checks of uh the the
seven for three Heming
code yeah so now I want to see a code
word of the Heming code around this
vertex rather than uh rather than
um U of the par check code
yeah
here yeah so for example let's say I
know this and
then know what the what the what the
code look like here but let's say this
is a code word of the of the Heming code
yeah then this would be allowed yeah but
for example think this would not be
allowed because the Heming code has
distance
three okay but now because um the graph
is is kind of expanding or well
connected as I call it
if I um if I want to generate a nonzero
code word yeah I have to kind of put
some non-zero elements somewhere so let
me kind of put them
here now I see that because uh this node
kind of sees a single one yeah I have to
kind of make up for it by kind of adding
more ones let's say here and here
yeah but these these expander graphs
they look locally like trees yeah so so
whenever I kind of try to fix something
I guess kind of create more problems for
myself I put more
ones so on and so on yeah and I I hope I
can kind of I know gives you the
intuition that uh in order to kind of
fulfill all checks I actually have to
kind of put ones on
uh on order and uh edges yeah assuming
that the graph is like well enough
expanding and this local code has like
large enough distance yeah uh if you
have not seen this before before then I
I would kind of urge you to kind of
check all this paper because it's a very
very simple very elegant very nice very
nice proof um of
this um let me also mention just because
I like the notation very much and if
you're in homology afinado then you
might like this so
mulam this is exactly something that we
kind of already know in homology this is
called
homology with local coefficients
okay and this is traditionally uh
denoted XL where this is my
graph and this is my local
code
okay
um so these are the ingredients any
questions while I eras the board
so D you said that U if the graph
presumably the K graph is sufficiently
well connected um and the way you define
the K graph it depends on the generating
set like I mean I guess it's probably a
basic algebra question or something but
could you imagine a situation where you
have the same group but you take like a
different generating basis such that um
now the K graph is somehow like I mean
which two different choices with one
choice you get the other one yeah indeed
it does depend it does depend on the on
the generating Set uh actually let me
let me kind of give you the example so
um um okay let me let me say two things
so so first of all we know that like one
way of kind of getting a symmetric way
expanding K graph actually optimally
expanding is um and this is a result due
tooski Phillips and Zak and also mulam
um that if we take G to be
psl2 fq then there exist uh uh
distinguished generating set yeah such
that it's optimally expanding it turns
out that if we take any um finite simple
group and we take a random generating
set of aici size this will also be an
optimal
expander
um okay um now kind of knowing this and
uh kind of knowing that we can take
random random local codes yeah they will
have have large distance uh this let
myself to conjecture um
conjecture um yeah B
products over G uh need to
good
yeah and this was uh speically proven by
pev so they gave an engenious
proof
umf in
21 and um essentially what they showed
is they use a higher dimensional
version
uh of the sub
proof yeah but uh in contrary to the
experiment proof which is like very
short and sweet yeah it's it's a really
a two Force it's like really really
complicated to kind of make your way uh
through this um uh
um uh through this uh High dimensional
object um so let me just kind of because
I kind of introduced this notation
earlier let me just kind of write down
what it looks like so we have C and then
we have our kph X then we look
L and then we have this um linearized
balance
product I didn't I didn't fully Define
this but I just um show you the
mation and then this we can actually
identify with c c and
then uh the balance product of the two k
graphs and then
we have this local system oh sorry uh
this local code so this is just a Balan
product
um TSL
to P
expers in um the paper by uh and others
they call the three cubc paper they call
this Left
Right
complex yeah where U this essenti of
comes from the fact that we have our
group kind of acting from the left and
the right yeah on our on our graph um
yeah and this
is uh a tensor
code yeah and um the technical
ingredient
that um found in order to kind of show
that okay so so maybe I should say uh
essentially we would want to mimic um
the proof of liy and sorry of tence zmo
um where we want to show that uh these
kind of cancellations that can happen in
products don't happen and the technical
ingredient here was kind of showing that
um kind of knowing that um random uh
like tensor tensor codes made out of
random random codes have a certain
robustness property and
I refer to product talk um who will
cover
this just a clode or no this is a good
good
quote wait um is this does this like a
quality hold for any Group G um that you
the bottom here or is this specific to
the no this this holds for any Group G
there's like a slightly there's like a
difference between so you can do
different things you can have dualize
these codes and then it doesn't work
anymore there's also something else you
can do um so let me have also mention
this let me let me first write down let
me first erase the B and then write some
things down
um I guess Nicholas this itself is an
identity probably it's not that what you
do with it is yeah yeah of course yeah
yeah sure sure sure yeah yeah um I mean
in some sense this is just a definition
right I mean this is already the the
mathematical object this is just like
different way of describing it right I
mean this is just like saying okay I
take this product and I get something I
could also just kind of first do the
product here and then kind of plug on
this like tensor code everywhere and I
know that it fits
um but uh yeah I just like it because
it's kind of I don't know associativity
looks kind of nice
um all right um also more than that you
really use the right hand side to do the
analysis right because you sort of
because you use properties of the oh
yeah yeah yeah so so so yeah that's kind
of important thing because okay let me
kind of say one more technical thing so
I mean I think what what one could have
tried is just take some this is a high
dimensional expander yeah and just to
kind of mimic the of P construction uh
naively you would have just kind of
taken a high dimension expander and just
put like a local system on it right
which is exactly what what Z is in 1D
you just do it in high Dimensions VOA
you have like high dimension object
which has the same properties as spean
you're done the the I think the main
ingredient is essentially kind of that
you can kind of build high dimension
expanders using a product construction
and this really helps you because you
can always kind of use kunet and all
these kind of things you kind of have
more more of a handle right if I would
take like some some weird BR tits
building yeah then this becomes much
more complicated uh
yeah
okay um okay
oh okay
um okay then let me just briefly sketch
the arguments so first of all I should
also kind of say Le Z came up with a
very nice
construction so what they did was um
just a different
way of
associating uh the T
code yeah and um that essentially to a
much more symmetric construction yeah
which is makes things much ni to handle
um and um yeah let me just with the
cartoon picture of the
argument
uh so the idea is we just
take
element
uh W in
CZ which is
smaller such
that W is uh let's say founded
by some Dela
n and then we
show
um that there
exists an
element uh
Y and CX
p
such
that Omega
time Y is smaller stly smaller than
Omega uh W okay and this is like the
crucial step right essentially kind of
relies on the fact that um if we take
some some Loop yeah in this in this
structure yeah then there's always some
some piece where we can kind of do some
flips yeah but these flips will be
boundaries yeah this will reduce the the
the length
yeah um but now kind of we just kind of
plug this back in yeah right because we
know no it's still kind smaller than
Delta n right we just kind of decreased
it so uh by iterating we know that this
will now be in CX per yeah so it's not
it doesn't kind of go into the distance
because we know that for CS
codes so uh know that
UHS
code
distance because the
distance so
DZ definition
so w in CZ but then
removed
C
okay so let me just kind say it once
once more we take an an element in CZ
here which is small enough yeah then
expansion tells us we can actually kind
of make it smaller yeah just by kind of
adding elements in CX per yeah just
adding these checks uh this tells us
that it has to be in CX per yeah but
then it doesn't going to go into the
distance right because this is going
take a note so this has to be larger
than
this
okay
um any questions regarding this
okay since we are run over time let me
kind of just so regarding that argument
that argument is what um uh posle used
or is that what is this argument oh yeah
this this is POS col argument
yeah me again so the main really great
thing that they do is essent kind of
show that uh um the structure is
essentially still expanding like it's
still a boundary expander yeah uh and um
and then essentially kind of show that
uh kind this this whole argument go
through yeah which is is
Tri
um okay let me kind give like couple
more references and then I will wrap up
so um for
similar
arguments by this I mean
expansion um can be used for decoding
uh
again the the um the idea was already
present in s Fan's paper where they kind
of show that you can decode expander
codes using a linear time decoder um
again the idea is essentially that if we
have uh uh some some error it will
generate syndromes and by kind of
flipping bits now we can always kind of
reduce the syndrome and this gives us a
greedy linear time decoder um and this
was developed
by uh D for the quum case
Shay uh
Lyn and
vck and also for uh the um construction
by liy and
Z
by
T both
in3 actually like only a few days apart
from one another so it's very hot topic
um okay um then another thing I should
mention uh so this is not only useful
for for for coding Theory I said uh like
one other thing was um you can use this
to uh Define c cubed ltcs the only
difference is now you don't put your
degrees of freedom so you don't put
cubits on edges but you put bits on the
faces yeah this defines uh a a CQ LTC
yeah so instead of taking the first
mology group you take the second mology
group yeah of the same object and the
third thing was uh turns out that um
this distance proof can be can be
generalized in in a certain way and this
gives rise to a a certain clustering
property of uh of things which are close
to code words and this then was very
useful for for proving a result in
hamiltonian complexity um by anru and
myself and chimy Nika I think jimy will
talk about this
in
in okay uh since I'm already over time
let me of stop here thank you very
much maybe a quick question before we
head off
lunch these people are hungry so thanks
again nichas for talks and uh we'll see
you
all
submit speed
talk